Speaker 1: And finally, real quick here, I do
want to mention one other story that happened this
week there, because I found this just absolutely
fascinating. And that is, of course, the fact that
Mo Brooks, the now lame duck Republican member
of Congress, because he lost his runoff election
this week to Katie Britt, came out shortly after
losing that election and said, you know what,
I think I'm ready to sit down with
the January six committee now.
Now, he had previously been subpoenaed. However,
he had not been served his subpoena because
he was back home and campaigning, trying
to win the race that he ultimately lost.
But the timing of that sure is interesting,
isn't it, now that the dust has settled,
now that he knows his political career is
at least at a temporary end. Now he says,
I'll go ahead and talk to you. Now, of course, he
does have some stipulations. Here's what he says.
He says, My basic requirement is it be in public
so the public can see it so they don't get bits
and pieces dribbled out. Fine. I'm good with that.
He also wants to see the material they have on him
and the questions that they're going to be asking
ahead of time. Okay. I'll give you that as well.
But I do not think it is a coincidence. That he
has finally agreed to talk to this committee.
That, of course, is clearly going after Donald
Trump. After he lost his election. Possibly
because Donald Trump pulled his endorsement from
him. I think Mo Brooks is out for revenge. And I
think Mo Brooks understands that the best way to
get that revenge on Donald Trump is to go sit down
with that committee and tell them everything
they know. Mo Brooks, of course, as everybody
remembers, is the guy that were the bulletproof
vest to go speak at the stop the steal rally.
It has also been reported. He says it's not true,
but it has been reported that members of his staff
were actually working with the Stop the Steal
organizers to help put the whole thing together.
So Mo Brooks has some things to tell you. No doubt
about that. Mo Brooks has some stories to tell.
And I hope that he gets the chance to
tell them. Now, ordinarily, I would not
be in favor of the committee giving in to his
demands. Right. You've subpoenaed him. You
don't have to give in to anything but. If it means
getting dirt on Trump that we otherwise might not
get because Brooks wants to challenge it in court
or whatever he may choose to do. I say Give in.
Put him on TV. Put it back in prime time. And let
everybody here what little Mo Brooks has to say
about Donald Trump, the man who screwed him
over in his quest to be a United States senator.
We have to take a quick break, but you can
get more from me on my YouTube channels.
Check me out at YouTube.com. Slash the ring of
fire and YouTube.com slash. Fair and balanced.
I'm fair. And Cozens in for David
Pakman. And we'll be back with more